[Music]
with everything costing more in a
recession on the horizon we can all use
a little cash back from our everyday
purchases right we're hearing from a
consumer finance expert about how to
make that happen
inflation is soaring and even after
you've cut out discretionary purchases
you still may not have enough to afford
this higher cost of living have your
spending work in your favor consumer
finance expert andrea warrock says try a
new credit card credit card rewards give
you cash back for different spending
categories but you really have to figure
out where you spend the most money to
make sure you get a card that aligns
with that so look at your year-end
statement from last year did you spend
more on travel dining out groceries you
can look up cash back cards at
cardrates.com
review the different options to find the
best one for your spending style other
cashback tools include couponcabin.com
with thousands of online retailers and
merchants if you're ordering your
groceries online you can get three
percent back at vons.com up to two
dollars and fifty cents back at
instacart they have cashback for
ubereats grubhub
gap macy's kohl's walmart amazon the
point is most of us do our shopping
online these days and so easy to click
through couponcabin.com and make some
extra cash check out sites like inbox
dollars and survey junkie they pay you
anywhere from a few bucks up to 50 bucks
to take online surveys you can take a
survey while you're binge watching your
favorite show on netflix or if you're
traveling and waiting to board a flight
pull it up on your phone why not turn
that spare time into some extra spending
cash
and fetch rewards is also another cash
back tool every time you're done
shopping you take a photo of that
receipt and you earn points to put
toward free gift cards christian
[Music]